and to do this I'm joined by the lovely
Helen Ann Smith
um who is Sky's Asia correspondent we're
also joined by Tom Cheshire your
predecessor who covered that patch for
nearly four and a half years four and a
half years okay um but you're now Sky's
data and forensics correspondent Tom can
I start with you because you spent many
years didn't you investigating reporting
on the uyghur community so who are they
and what have they been through I mean
they've been through a tremendous amount
I mean the uyghurs are recognized as an
ethnic minority in China is around 11 or
12 million in China there's also jaspera
um lots of connections with countries
like Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan but big
communities in Turkey as well Saudi
Arabia mainly Muslim they're in xinjiang
which is in the far Northwest of the
country they've been there for hundreds
of years still have weaker's Main in the
south of the country and still you know
very uh clear identity when you visit
those bars hello Dan you have recently
been to xinjiang and we'll talk about
that more in a moment but Tom you know
when kovid hit xinjiang was suddenly
locked down and and only now we're
starting to get access for Western
journalists to go in there but what did
you know of the area yeah I mean it's
all it's a huge huge area to start with
you've got you know amazing mountains uh
things like that it's got these
Flatlands grasslands too
um then you've got big cities like room
two which is its capital which is has a
lot more hand Chinese so that's the
dominant ethnicity uh in China but if
you go close to the Border Southwest
kashgar hotel and places like that have
a lot more of a uyghur identity and what
happened with covert though I mean this
happened everywhere in China yeah very
hard to get places because you had these
Health codes but especially with
xinjiang so it's always been a sensitive
region during that pandemic you know it
wasn't even the case that you might get
quarantined it just you couldn't get a
fly there because either Beijing had a
case or xinjiang had a case I really
spend a lot of time in isolation so for
a long time we didn't really know what
was going on in the ground tell us I
mean you you recently got back from
xinjiang it's an absolutely beautiful
Province I mean you know I was looking
out the window when our plane came into
land at just the most astonishing
mountain ranges you know snow capped and
then you sort of flew on a bit into this
vast deserts the cities are ancient and
kashgar for example has this utterly
stunning Old Town sort of build to this
sort of sandstone kind of a yellow brick
if you like and it really is kind of a
beautiful place in a place that once had
a very very strong cultural identity and
we will talk more about this but that's
a cultural identity that sort of slowly
gradually been kind of whitewashed kind
of by the Chinese government in recent
years and it's you know really been a
sort of a five six years very concerted
campaign to sort of control and oppress
them to put it for quite frankly I mean
there was a series of Terror attacks
back in the sort of late 2000s early
2010s sort of perpetrated by uyghur
people who kind of felt oppressed in
various ways and then there was a you
know a number of riots there was
violence on both sides actually uh we go
against Han and Han against uyghur but
as a result of that sort of Xi Jinping
government launched what they called a
strike hard campaign that started in
2014 actually but it really intensified
in 2017 and essentially under the guise
of anti-terror the uyghur people were
essentially arrested on mass for tiny
tiny things such as owning a book that
was banned or
having a beard having once had a foreign
holiday having a relative living abroad
these people arrested detained and out
of these sort of camps that got set up I
mean there's just awful awful stories of
torture of beatings of force
sterilization in some cases we have
stories of children being separated from
their parents put into boarding schools
where they weren't allowed to speak the
uighur language which is a sort of
turkic language you know truly truly
atrocious Crackdown but that that really
culminated sort of towards the start of
your tenure there Tom is that right in
sort of 2018 yeah I mean yeah we're
talking like million two million people
yeah the way it sort of starts 2014 you
have that national campaign strike down
when Xi Jinping visits in 2014 one of
those Terror attacks happens in intense
fires and they bring a man called Chen
to angwa who was running to bet as party
secretary
um doing some effective repression there
Xi Jinping brings him in he arrives in
2016 2016 2017 is when you start to see
these camps being built this Mass
internment and everything that entails
that Helen
scribes and it is just a huge huge
campaign when you start to try and visit
and understand what's going on you know
it was very hard to get at that story
the sort of level of obstruction by the
authorities was extraordinary in terms
of you arrive there and you're being
followed by eight cars you try and go to
these camps and you know there'll be a
road accident one day where you see a
scooter very gently leaning against a
car and they say well this holds Road
shut we can't go it's like okay fine
we'll come back the next day sadly
there's been another accident
um involving a different scooter in a
car or some they're fixing an electrical
fault these re-education camps you've
spoken to people from the uyghur
community
um but what they're saying activists are
saying actually the uighur
sort of culture you said it's been
whitewashed as being threatened what's
the sense from this community about how
they're being targeted Helen certainly
sort of back in the sort of the height
of the Crackdown them being targeted was
just it was just complete I think people
felt that they could barely kind of step
outside they could certainly not go to
the mosque they couldn't openly talk in
their sort of native language without
feeling some sort of threat certainly
anything as dramatic as talking to a
foreign journalist that would be a
direct arrest and there are mosques that
still exist in xinjiang and there are
cultural sites that still exist but a
lot of them based on satellite imagery
and on-the-ground Reporting have been
destroyed or at the very least of
de-islamified so some of the kind of
Islamic architecture taken away from
some of these sites you know in our
recent trip we saw for instance mosques
that are now shops in kind of the old
town and things like that and it's yeah
and sometimes in China China is such a
fast developing Place sometimes you want
to give you know this give them the
benefit of the doubt there's a lot of
development that happens all around the
country especially under the guys
poverty alleviation that's a lot of what
officials would say if we went to a
graveyard which had just been bulldozed
and you know this is a lot you know
people buried there for decades and
decades we found a child's bone not just
left out there in the dirt and that
starts to feel a lot more deliberate and
targeted China will always say we
protect our ethnic minorities and every
propaganda video you'll see It'll have
weaker people dancing or cooking food
and that those are the two allowed
activities they do in a sort of a model
minority sort of feel to that but that
obviously doesn't Encompass all of we've
got it's not just dancing the whole time
there was one thing we saw when we were
there that I was like wow I feel that
really sort of encapsulates that sense
of what weaker culture now looks and
feels like in xinjiang and that was so
in kashgar's Old City and it's very
touristy and it has been very actively
designed and and sort of kind of
preserved in that sense you get this in
quite a few Chinese cities actually that
are tourist hot spots you get these
shops where people can go and rent
costumes to then have sort of photos
taken in the kind of local costume and
you get these hand Chinese people
dressing up in eager costume kind of
having their photos taken if a weaker
person were to just walk around in their
native dress I mean you just never saw
it and I I don't know what would happen
it's probably pretty likely that they
would have gotten arrested certainly
back in 2017 for that I went to
kashgar's main mosque and hung out there
for an hour or so just to kind of watch
people coming and going we didn't see
one person who we believed to be a
worshiper going into that mosque we saw
groups and groups of tourists going into
the mosque and yes we might have missed
one person here or there who looked like
a tourist and was perhaps a worshiper
but it really didn't feel that way and I
think that was pretty telling what are
the allegations then let's just set this
out the allegations against China for
whitewashing the Vega Community what are
those yeah I mean especially starting in
2017 this Mass internment of anywhere
between one and two million um because
we don't know how many just because it
there were so many but China hasn't been
Frank with those figures really
vocational training they've never said
how many people graduated properly
they've given some figures but they're
incomplete we went to a different part
near Tim Dao in the East where we're
pretty sure they were using forced
uighur labor in seafood processing for
instance so uyghur work is exported
around the country without any freedom
of movement had to be signed off by a
party official there Captain dormitory
is kept very close aisle and then beyond
that sort of um the cultural side of
things as helenan's talking about those
signs of identity being clamped down on
only the very prescribed this is what
you can do according to Chinese
Communist Party uyghurs abroad being
separated from their children we spoke
to people in Turkey who hadn't seen
their children for a very long time
moment so they saw it on dayin which is
the Chinese Tick Tock of the kids saying
I love China China was my flag it was
his child he hadn't seen five days he's
speaking Mandarin rather than speaking
uyghur and these boarding schools we
went to visit them as well and these are
happening in all sorts of places and
then also the transnational depressions
when we were sort of starting reporting
the story it was it was very tricky to
get people to speak because they were
scared about their family it still is
it's still so hard there's so much at
stake for them they get Chinese spies
trying to convince them to spy on the
uyghur community there's a lot of
intimidation and pressure that goes on
uyghurs abroad Helen on your recent trip
to xinjiang what did you notice did you
get close to the the camps yeah so we
did there has been a change and there
has been a step change and I think
that's part of the reason we wanted to
go on the most recent trip we did to
sort of figure out in that time during
zero covid where people haven't really
been able to get in and out you know
how's that policy moved on what does it
look like it's also really important to
say that China face a lot of
international condemnation for this and
a lot of embarrassment actually I think
I think China to a degree didn't quite
anticipate the world comparing what was
going on in xinjiang to Nazi
concentration camps you know it was
embarrassing know Tony Blair in 2014
gives an interview to Global times where
he says we you know China and the UK and
Russia we all have a common cause which
is Islamic terrorism combating that
China's always referred to the prevent
program as a model of that we're just
doing something like that yeah quite and
then when it sort of transpired to what
was going on in xinjiang was was clearly
something of an entirely different
League you know China suffered not just
reputational damage but major economic
damage as well there's a you know a law
in America for example where no product
that has any connection whatsoever to
xinjiang can be sold so I think there
was a sense from China that the policy
needed to develop right in the time that
it's been sort of semi-closed really
because of covert there were rumors that
had come out that things had taken a
step down that the mass arrests had
stopped that some uyghurs were being
released from these detention camps and
it's been very difficult to assess
whether that's true so what our sort of
aim was when we went was to try and
figure that out so we broadly tried to
go and visit as many places that we were
aware of that were former re-education
camps or detention centers or prisons of
some description and to try and assess
what those places were being used for of
the kind of what you would call the
lower security sites that we visited the
ones that were being used for
re-education so the ones where people
were kind of being put in sort of what
classrooms you know taught Chinese the
ones that the Chinese described as
vocational were largely not being used
for that purpose anymore so we we
visited 14 such sites and of those you
know eight were very visibly schools now
what type of school a little bit
difficult to verify
two were completely abundant sort of
Dusty Windows you could peer through the
cracks and see these kind of strange old
playgrounds with sort of kind of rubbish
blowing through them there was only one
that we went to that we felt probably
was potentially still being used as some
form of vocational school as the Chinese
like to call it there was a banner
across sort of describing it as a
vocational school it was set right next
to a prison it was relatively heavily
securitized Again difficult to say for
100 certain but that's how we felt but
what is really interesting about that so
you know over 90 percent of the
re-education sites we visited were
clearly no longer being used for that
purpose and China said back in 2019 that
everybody who was involved in vocational
re-education has now graduated so that's
what China wanted us to see that's the
message right that it's over people have
been re-educated they have been released
however the statistics the Survivor
testimony all Point towards the fact
that although some of these re-education
centers might be closed the people who
were locked up in them are not
necessarily free we know that from
family members that we have spoken to
who say you know my brother was held in
that abandoned camp that you visited he
might not be there anymore but we know
he's not free he was given a 14-year
prison sentence for instance there was a
enormous spike in arrests in 2017-2018
but there was also this huge jump in
2017 of the proportion of people given a
very lengthy sentence so the proportion
of people given a sentence longer than
five years jumped from sort of 11 to 87
so just statistically those people are
still going to be locked up somewhere
and the prisons absolutely in every
single case were absolutely operational
right fearsome fearsome intimidating
places you know really watch Towers
watchtowers High walls barbed wire
fences and of course as journalists as
well you always know you're being sort
of watched and followed and it was sort
of nerve-wracking filming around them it
felt tense I think what we're seeing now
compared to what Tom and team saw back a
few years ago it's almost sort of a
formalization of this internment a
legitimization they're now kind of
putting these people into the justice
system and yes okay it might not be
justice as we would understand it but
it's almost trying to make the process
slightly more invisible slightly more
acceptable to the world but these people
are not free and they're still and
turned on very very weak charges I think
when they come up with the idea of
vocational training centers re-education
camps it's not a bizarre idea in Charlie
it's had a long history of this part of
the culture in a way and so when it sees
that backlash it's like okay let's
formalize this let's put it in a more
Western friendly way when perhaps if
they've done that from the start it
would have been different like you say
trying to make it more accessible to the
world even though it is not acceptable
I want to talk about the shrine that you
both attempted visits to in the second
book The response from the government in
China and we've touched on it a little
bit but what what are they saying that
they're trying to reintroduce these
these prisons and maybe de-escalate the
education camps as they call it there's
two things we should discuss here
actually I think it's what they say and
also how they behaved in terms of how
they treated us as a team versus how
they treated Tom as a team of course
when you do these stories you always as
a journalist put in your the right of
reply to kind of the the party that you
are sort of suggesting um might have
fallen foul of certain standards of
behavior and you know for years China
you guys would put those right responses
in and China would never respond we
actually got a response which I want to
get a message out to the World by a
western German absolutely there is a
sense that they are engaging in a way
that they hadn't before some of this
response we've heard before I mean they
said the allegations of so-called camps
are sheer lies the vocational education
and training centers were set up in
accordance to the law so remember they
always talk about as being a school a
vocational you know they said that
everyone who was involved is now
graduated they say that everyone is
leading normal lives that they're not
subject to any sort of special
preconditions but there's just one bit
and you can sort of read between the
lines here kind of as much as you like
they sort of said in their statement
through Education and Training the
trainee's overall capability as well as
their awareness of the nation's
citizenship and rule of law was
significantly enhanced they also came to
see the harmful nature of terrorism and
extremism and broke free from the sway
of Terror and extremist ideas so they're
not denying that these schools exist for
the purpose of re-educating people and
that kind of subtle Nuance there that
you can read that we have taught these
people the right way you know it speaks
through right and of course we looking
in from the outside and certainly the
uyghur people would probably feel that
you know their their way of thinking
wasn't terrorist or extremists but that
is absolutely how the Chinese see it
there was a terrorism problem whether
one million two million people are all
terrorists they need to be locked up for
having a beard for things we've talked
about the proportion of the response
there that sort of speaks to that so
we've re-educated all these people who
might hang extremists thought two
million people having extremist thoughts
yeah it seems unlikely we get followed
and surveilled in almost every story
that we do in China so we were expecting
high high high levels of surveillance
and intimidation and harassment in
xinjiang because that's what teams have
experienced in the past and it's not
that uncommon in China but even in
xinjiang the most sensitive of provinces
we were really surprised how much
license we were given it's interesting
isn't it that change of Direction when
you both went to visit a cultural like a
shrine you both had different
experiences so Tom what happened to you
yeah so we wanted to go and visit the
um Imam Zim Shrine yeah
further out the city
uh very similar experience blocked roads
to start with so you drive a bit further
on and it's it's across these sort of
sand dunes so Mark hope the cameraman
live sort of hop out uh get ready for a
walk and it's quite a long walk over you
know probably about a couple miles
through like pretty effective desert
desert yeah and then as we're sort of
getting a bit closer
um we see on the horizon just there's a
few figures you're starting to pick up
the pace but they had as often there's
about a group of eight men
um quite big Lads
um and you know they're goons basically
they're there to sort of enforce that we
try and go on they push us back uh try
to grab the camera again there's quite a
lot of them and so you know we give up
at that point we never see the shrine
that was 2019 2019. yeah so we went
obviously a few weeks ago 2023
completely different experience we drove
out we were kind of expecting roadblocks
they didn't come we knew we were being
followed at that time but nobody stopped
us we drove all the way down almost
about 100 meters away from where the
shrine was and then there was one guy on
a you see them a lot in China it's a
little sort of almost like a motorized
farm vehicle I'd call it one guy and he
was weaker in appearance speaking uyghur
actually and he was like saying no no
you can't you can't we walked around him
there was no big problem we walked up to
the shrine this place is one of the
holiest places for the uyghur people it
was a place of pilgrimage it's a place
that apparently at all times of year
there would be people there but
particularly when we were there in May
apparently that's normally Festival time
so there would be you know many hundreds
of people there there used to be a big
Bazaar that was held next to it almost
like a fun fair sort of vibe that
families would come and spend time there
was a sort of apparently a mosque
complex at one point and then people
would come and they'd bring these flags
up and sort of pin them in the shrine
and perform their acts of worship
um and we arrived there as I said with
this one man who was vaguely trying to
stop us but not particularly concertedly
um and it was just silent I mean the
bizarre area had all gone all the
infrastructure around had gone the
shrine itself was still there of course
without all the flags that people put in
but it was Eerie desolate it was silent
I found it quite sad actually so what do
you think this means then for the uyghur
community and then also
change in policy
say for China's attitudes towards the
uighur community what next I find it
very hard to see how in any sort of
immediate years things go back to what
they were right people are terrified
there you can't speak to people there
even outside China and I did an
interview with a Survivor outside China
who actually left xinjiang in relatively
recent times so saw kind of some of this
change of policy she was absolutely
terrified they just simply do not feel
that they can go to the mosque they
simply do not feel that they can teach
weaker to their children they simply do
not feel that they can live their kind
of cultural identity in the way that
they probably would want to and that
that will be lasting yeah it's hard to
see how it gets worse really I mean it's
been they've been through a horrible
horrible back but as we know so many
people are still in prison the culture
eroded hollowed out
um it's a horrible place but you know
you go to anywhere in xinjiang and all
the butcher's knives are changed the
table sort of that level of
securitization that people have to deal
with on a daily basis I think maybe the
thing that um is hardening for the Wigan
Community is the attention it has got
abroad especially in terms of sanctions
so the um Helen I mentioned the forced
labor and how that's banned in the US
that's had a really big impact on it you
see um them trying to do this uh show
everyone that the re-education is over
and they're hoping the wild will forget
and I think what we're your community
want especially the expat uyghur
Community is still to have that
attention still to have journalists like
headline going there showing the world
what it's like day-to-day life for
people in xinjiang I think probably has
improved a bit actually because you know
actually just the day-to-day high level
of securitization in xinjiang has taken
a step down so there was a time where
even to go into any larger shop or
restaurant or hotel you'd have to have a
full kind of metal ID scan like sort of
airport style you know you were you know
Road stops police checks on every road
you don't have to have the full body
scans everything no no and there's been
a real notable dialing down of some of
that stuff and I think again that's
probably a purposeful decision because I
think it's not just the weaker people
but also the hand people who live in
xinjiang I mean it must have been
exhausting to live like that but perhaps
it also speaks to a confidence of the
authorities and I think that really I
really felt that in the air when we were
there you know they have done enough
over the past however many years to to
make people feel
too scared to to put a foot out of line
and so they know they can sort of
withdraw some of that security apparatus
that was the aim that was the aim
correct yeah this huge repression
entirely correct it's tubeless goals so
there is a sense of mission complete how
that then plays out over future years if
there is a sort of some sort of
resurgence of that sort of weaker
identity and how that plays out and how
the Chinese government respond who knows
yes this policy is in a new phase
um but goodness what those people have
been through and experienced is
horrendous and that's exactly it's worth
very among what China's direction of
travel in China generally we could
people have borne the brunt of that
absolutely
um really being targeted singled out
treated appallingly but the direction of
travel of China and this Xi Jinping ever
since he took power has been more
controlled by the authorities over every
aspect of life and that that extends
across Society whether it's in business
and Tech
um covid was a very you know real
articulation of that it was very visible
especially for people in Shanghai and
suddenly locked down they thought they
looked at this and thought well xinjiang
uyghurs that's a long way away you know
they're troublemakers they're terrorists
then it happens to them people have been
reminded all through Chinese Society the
Primacy of the party headed by Xi
Jinping guys it's it's so fascinating
it's wonderful to have you both together
here on this podcast my thanks to Helen
Ann Smith and Tom Cheshire um you can
also you can check out your reports on
the Sky News YouTube page just to type
in uh uyghur that's where lots of your
reports are too Tom so thank you so much
for joining us here today on the podcast
produced by Annie Joyce and the podcast
editor is Paul stamworth foreign